This past Monday, a guy named Dan Curry got into his car to drive across the country from the East Coast to California alone. And to pass the time, he brought along 16 hours of Spanish language lessons on CD. I reached him in his car on Wednesday.
上周一，一个叫丹·库里的家伙独自开车横穿全国，从东海岸前往加州。为了打发时间，他带了16个小时的西班牙语CD课程。周三，我在他车上联系到了他。
So I have some questions for you.
所以我有些问题要问你。
OK.
好的。
Donde esta, usted?
Donde esta-- oh, god. I know what that means.
Donde esta-- 哦，天哪。我知道那是什么意思。
What's it mean?
是什么意思？
Donde esta. You.
Donde esta. 你。
It means, where are you?
意思是，你在哪？
When I reached Dan, the answer was Odessa, Texas. He was just outside Odessa, Texas. It was actually kind of a big moment for him. After 14 hours of listening and practicing Spanish out loud with his CDs, he had just tried out his Spanish for the very first time with a person, an actual person, a Spanish speaking person. He was ordering lunch.
当我联系到丹时，他的回答是德克萨斯州的敖德萨。他就在德克萨斯州敖德萨郊外。对他来说，这其实是一个相当重要的时刻。在听了14个小时并大声练习西班牙语CD后，他刚刚第一次与一个真实的人，一个讲西班牙语的人，尝试使用他的西班牙语。他正在点午餐。
I pulled up to a place. It's a little stand. They had a little drive-in, drive through area. So I went and ordered two pollas, pollo tacos and un-- I did it all en espanol-- and un carne asada. And it should've been about $4 or $5. But the girl, she was bilingual, kind of rolled her eyes when I was talking. She said something to me in Spanish. And I said, "Oh, si, si, si." And I ended up buying $26 worth of stuff. Instead of getting two chicken tacos, I got eight. The carne asada, what I got was a big vat of it. It was about $19, and all these shells. I was too embarrassed, so I bought them.
我把车开到一个地方。那是一个小摊位。他们有一个小小的免下车服务区。所以我去点了两份鸡肉塔可，还有——我全程都用的西班牙语——还有一份烤肉。原本应该只要4或5美元。但那个女孩，她是双语的，我说话时她翻了个白眼。她用西班牙语对我说了些什么。我说：“哦，是的，是的，是的。”最后我买了价值26美元的东西。我本想买两份鸡肉塔可，结果买了八份。那份烤肉，我买了一大桶。大约花了19美元，还有所有这些面饼。我太尴尬了，所以就买了。
I said, "Quiero caliente--" And I didn't know the word for sauce. I haven't learned the word sauce yet. So I said "sauce." And she switched to English at that point for me.
我说：“Quiero caliente--”我不知道酱汁的单词。我还没学到“酱汁”这个词。所以我说了“sauce”。那一刻她改用英语跟我交流了。
Wait, the word for sauce is salsa. Haven't you heard the word salsa?
等等，酱汁的单词是salsa。你没听过salsa这个词吗？
Salsa is sau-- Oh, salsa means sauce? I thought salsa meant salsa.
Salsa是sau-- 哦，salsa意思是酱汁？我还以为salsa就是莎莎酱呢。
I'm scared.
我好怕。
I got you. Put your feet on the pedal. I got you.
我有你呢。把脚放在踏板上。我会扶着你的。
Don't let go.
别松手。
Sunday, in suburban New Jersey, eight-year-old Ruby Melman went out with her mom and dad to try-- this was her second attempt-- to learn to ride a bike. Her dad ran along beside her, holding the handle bars.
周日，在新泽西郊区，八岁的鲁比·梅尔曼和她的父母一起出去尝试——这是她的第二次尝试——学习骑自行车。她爸爸跑在她身边，扶着车把。
Keep going. Pedal, pedal. Oh, Ruby, you've got to pedal. Why are you stopping?
继续。蹬啊，蹬啊。哦，鲁比，你得蹬。你为什么要停下来？
Because it's scaring me.
因为我害怕。
It took about a half an hour for her to get it.
她花了大约半小时才学会。
Good. You've got to pedal OK?
很好。你得蹬，好吗？
Let go.
松手吧。
You're not pedaling enough.
你蹬得不够。
And keep your eyes up, Ruby. Look forward. Look ahead.
还有，鲁比，眼睛朝前看。向前看。看前方。
Good, good.
好，很好。
There you go. Good job!
就这样。干得好！
Pedal, pedal.
蹬，蹬。
You got it! Keep going, keep going. Did you do it?
你学会了！继续，继续。你做到了吗？
Yes!
是的！
That was really good, Ruby.
那真的很棒，鲁比。
OK, let's try it again.
好，我们再试一次。
So I'm going to ride around the corner.
所以我打算骑着拐个弯。
So this is the first time you're getting on a bike since when?
所以这是你自什么时候起第一次骑自行车？
This is the first time in almost four years, three and a half, four years. Let's see if I can--
这是近四年来第一次，三年半，四年了。看看我能不能——
Saturday, on the north side of Chicago, my friend Beau O'Reilly, age 56, is getting on a bike again for the first time since he had both his knees replaced.
周六，在芝加哥北区，我的朋友博·奥赖利，56岁，在他双膝置换手术后第一次重新骑上自行车。
All right. Here we go. Here we go.
好了。我们走吧。出发了。
All right, both legs are going.
好，两条腿都在动。
Yes, and it's moving. It feels OK.
是的，它在动。感觉还可以。
How's your knees?
你的膝盖怎么样？
They hurt. Yeah. What?
它们疼。是啊。怎么了？
I have to say, we are kind of a sight. Beau, with his huge shock of grey hair. Me, trotting along beside him with the microphone. And then behind us, Beau's girlfriend, Judith, chasing after us down the sidewalk with his cane.
我不得不说，我们看起来真是一道奇观。博顶着那一头灰白的乱发。我拿着麦克风在他身边小跑。在我们后面，博的女友朱迪斯正拿着他的拐杖沿着人行道追着我们。
But that feels OK. A little winded. A little breathing. Feeling it, but feels all right.
但感觉还可以。有点喘。在呼吸。能感觉到（膝盖），但感觉还行。
At Ground Zero this week, on Thursday, President Obama laid a wreath. A woman named Theodosha Alexander was out on the sidewalk. She'd worked as a temp in the Twin Towers all through the '80s and '90s, knew tons of people who'd worked there. Since 9/11, she's generally avoided Lower Manhattan because of that. But she came down on Thursday, hoping it would feel different now that Osama bin Laden was dead.
本周四，在归零地，奥巴马总统敬献了花圈。一位叫西奥多莎·亚历山大的女士站在人行道上。她在80年代和90年代一直作为临时工在双子塔工作，认识很多在那里工作过的人。自9·11事件以来，因为那段记忆，她通常会避开曼哈顿下城。但她在周四赶了过来，希望能因为奥萨马·本·拉登已死而感到释怀。
It's like a relief that he's finally gone. You know, it's gone. No more. Maybe it's over. Maybe I won't have dreams about it. Well, I feel better right now. I feel great. I feel like they got him. They got him. They got him.
这就像是一种解脱，他终于不在了。你知道，结束了。没有了。也许一切都过去了。也许我再也不会做关于它的噩梦了。好吧，我现在感觉好多了。我感觉棒极了。我觉得他们抓到他了。他们抓到他了。他们抓到他了。
That same day, Thursday, at the hospital that US forces set up at Bagram Air Base to deal with US casualties in Afghanistan, there was no question that we are, of course, a nation that is still at war. Dr. Wade Gordon, one of three orthopedic surgeons there, says that it's been pretty steady the last six months, including this week, with Osama bin Laden gone.
就在那天，周四，在美军为处理阿富汗伤员而在巴格拉姆空军基地设立的医院里，毫无疑问，我们确实是一个仍在战争中的国家。韦德·戈登医生，那里的三位骨科医生之一，说过去六个月情况一直相当稳定，包括本周奥萨马·本·拉登已死之后。
This week has been pretty busy. We have been averaging probably between 8 and 12 new trauma patients each day.
这周一直相当忙。我们平均每天大约有8到12名新的创伤患者。
And so what kinds of injuries are those?
那都是些什么样的伤情？
Well, sadly, a large percentage of them are amputations from blast injuries from explosions. There's a fair number of gunshot wounds as well.
唉，很大一部分是爆炸造成的截肢。枪伤也相当多。
I saw a quote from a soldier, I think it was in the New York Times , who was in Afghanistan and said, "OK. Can I go home now?" And I'm wondering if you're hearing any of that.
我看到一个士兵说的话，我想是在《纽约时报》上看到的，他在阿富汗，说：“好吧。我现在能回家了吗？”我在想你是否有听到过类似的话。
Yeah, I think there's a lot of tongue-in-cheek joking about that. Yes, it's nice after 10 years, but I guess I'm not certain, really, how much that's going to impact the reality of what we're doing over here, of day to day putting guys back together again here.
是的，我想有很多那种半开玩笑的调侃。是的，10年了确实很想回去，但我猜我不确定，这真的会多大程度影响我们在这里的现实，每天在这里把那些小伙子重新拼凑起来的日常工作。
So much has happened this week. What else? In the Grand Canyon on Wednesday, high school freshmen were on a class trip.
本周发生了这么多事。还有什么？周三在大峡谷，高中新生正在进行班级旅行。
This is Lauren. We're walking down a trail to go to the Grand Canyon right now.
这是劳伦。我们现在正沿着小径走去大峡谷。
No. I know you wouldn't push anybody over the edge. But just don't even pretend to do it. OK? It's something we want to avoid. OK?
不。我知道你不会把任何人推下悬崖。但连假装都不要。好吗？这是我们要避免的事情。好吗？
Sunday, in a bar in New York City, patrons raised their glasses in remembrance of the bartender who ran the joint and lived upstairs till he was 90, Jack Loftus.
周日，在纽约市的一家酒吧里，客人们举杯缅怀那位经营这家店并住在楼上直到90岁去世的酒保，杰克·洛夫特斯。
Hear, hear. To Jack. Cheers.
说得好。为了杰克。干杯。
This is a neighborhood where guys drank a lot and got into fights. Jack was this six-foot-three fatherly figure who kept things calm. This guy, Tommy Pryor, said his own dad was a big drinker who Jack knew how to keep in line.
这是一个人们常喝酒且容易发生争执的社区。杰克是那种六英尺三英寸高的父辈人物，他能让事情保持平静。这个叫汤米·普赖尔的家伙说，他自己的父亲是个酒鬼，但杰克知道怎么管住他。
I loved Jack because I saw him love my father, respect him, take care of him when my father wasn't on his best behavior. And I felt I could trust Jack to help me control my father.
我爱杰克，因为我看着他爱我的父亲，尊重他，在他表现不佳时照顾他。我觉得我可以信任杰克帮我管教我父亲。
I'm Ira Glass. Every week in our show, of course, we choose a theme and bring you different kinds of stories on that theme. Today we are trying something we have never tried before. The theme this week is, This Week. Everything you're going to hear this hour has happened in the last seven days. We wanted big things and small things, the most important things happening in the country, and the most important things happening to people far from Washington, DC, far from the network news cameras. A portrait of seven days in the life of our country. From WBEZ Chicago, it's a special edition of This American Life , distributed by Public Radio International. Seven days in 60 minutes. Stay with us.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，当然，我们都会选择一个主题，并为您带来关于该主题的不同故事。今天我们要尝试一些以前从未做过的事情。本周的主题是：“这一周”。这一小时你听到的所有事情都发生在过去七天里。我们想要大事和小事，这个国家发生的最重要的事情，以及远离华盛顿特区、远离电视新闻摄像机的人们身上发生的最重要的事情。我国七天生活的缩影。来自芝加哥WBEZ，这是《美国生活》的特别版，由公共广播国际公司发行。60分钟回顾七天。请继续收听。
We were all worried planning this week's show, coming into the week with no tape gathered at all. We worried like, OK, what if there is no news? What if nothing interesting happens? And then, Sunday night, there was a small bit of news.
我们在策划本周节目时都很担心，因为进入这一周时根本没有任何录音素材。我们担心，万一没有新闻怎么办？万一没有有趣的事情发生怎么办？然后，周日晚上，出现了一则小新闻。
Tonight, I can report to the American people and to the world that the United States has conducted an operation that killed Osama bin Laden, the leader of al-Qaeda.
今晚，我可以向美国人民和全世界报告，美国已经开展了一项行动，击毙了基地组织领导人奥萨马·本·拉登。
That's President Obama, of course, Sunday night. One of our producers, Sarah Koenig, was in a college town, State College, Pennsylvania, where she heard the noise of students shouting and blowing horns and what sounded like fire crackers on Sunday night. And since she wasn't watching TV, she had no idea what this was about. She thought maybe they had won a big game or something. She actually called the cops, who also at that point had no idea what it was about. And all week, she kept thinking about the hugeness of the students' reaction.
当然，那是奥巴马总统，周日晚上。我们的制片人之一，莎拉·凯尼格，当时在一个大学城，宾夕法尼亚州的州立大学，她在周日晚上听到了学生们欢呼、吹喇叭的声音，听起来像是爆竹声。由于她没在看电视，她完全不知道发生了什么。她以为他们赢了一场大赛之类的。她甚至报了警，当时警察也不知道是怎么回事。整个一周，她一直在思考学生们的反应有多么巨大。
When I heard Monday morning about Osama bin Laden, my reaction was, "Oh, wow," at about that decibel. The difference between that and this [CROWD CHANTING USA AND CHEERING]-- This is what was happening about three blocks away when I called the cops on Sunday. Thousands, maybe 5,000 or 6,000 Penn State students massed on Beaver Avenue. You've probably seen the pictures or read the accounts by now, young people letting loose all over the country. Here, there was all kinds of patriotic singing. Someone lit a small fire, and kids were jumping over it. A guy dressed like Captain America was body surfing the crowd.
当我周一早上听说奥萨马·本·拉登的消息时，我的反应是：“哦，哇。”分贝大概就是那样。那与这个之间的区别——[人群高喊USA并欢呼]——这就是我周日报案时，在三个街区外发生的事情。成千上万，也许五六千名宾州州立大学的学生聚集在海狸大道上。你现在可能已经看过照片或读过报道了，全国各地的年轻人都在释放激情。在这里，各种爱国歌曲此起彼伏。有人点了一堆小火，孩子们跳过火堆。一个装扮成美国队长的家伙在人群上玩人体冲浪。
[CROWD NOISE]
[人群噪音]
And by the end of the week, there'd been a bunch of stories in the papers about these September 11 kids, the so-called millenials, young, loyal Americans for whom Osama bin Laden was the boogie man, their Voldemort. But I still didn't quite get it-- the taking to the streets, all the revelry. And I know I'm not 20 years old, and I like to go to bed around 11:30 instead of putting on my superhero outfit. But still, the difference between their reaction and that of everyone I know over 30-- that difference is a gulf.
到周末时，报纸上已经出现了一堆关于这些9·11一代孩子的故事，所谓的千禧一代，年轻、忠诚的美国人，对他们来说奥萨马·本·拉登就是怪物，是他们的伏地魔。但我还是不太明白——那种走上街头的行为，所有的狂欢。我知道我不满20岁，我喜欢11点半左右睡觉而不是穿上超级英雄套装。但即便如此，他们的反应与我认识的所有30岁以上的人的反应之间的差异——那是一个鸿沟。
So I asked some of the kids who were there that night. Where did this outpouring of feeling come from? Why did they take this news so personally? I'm just going to play you the tape from the interview that finally helped me understand it. The girl speaking is Lexi Belculfine. She's a junior. She's 20 years old, editor of the school's daily newspaper. She's got a poster of Dave Matthews above her bed. And what she explained to me is that her fear after September 11 wasn't some abstraction. It was real and lasting.
所以我问了一些那天晚上的孩子。这种情感的爆发从何而来？为什么他们把这个消息看得如此个人化？我打算给你们播放那段最终帮助我理解它的采访录音。说话的女孩是莱克茜·贝尔库尔芬。她是三年级学生。她20岁，是学校日报的编辑。她的床头贴着戴夫·马修斯的海报。她向我解释说，9·11之后她的恐惧并不是某种抽象的概念。它是真实且持久的。
I distinctly remember being very afraid for a very long time. Yeah, I definitely was. I guess it was just a realization of how quickly everything could be ripped out from under you, that these huge, catastrophic things can happen. That was really frightening. After September 11 I wouldn't even look at a plane, basically. I live 10 minutes from the Pittsburgh International Airport. So we watch the planes go right into the airport. And it just gave me this incredibly uneasy fear of planes, of flying. And you know, it's silly, but I was 11 and didn't understand it. And I needed something to be afraid of, so I chose flying.
我清楚地记得有一段很长的时间我非常害怕。是的，我确实很怕。我想那只是一种意识到一切可能在瞬间被夺走的感觉，这些巨大的、灾难性的事情可能会发生。那真的很令人恐惧。9·11之后我基本上连飞机都不敢看。我住在离匹兹堡国际机场10分钟路程的地方。所以我们看着飞机直接飞进机场。这给了我一种对飞机、对飞行的难以名状的恐惧。你知道，这很傻，但我当时才11岁，不明白这些。我需要害怕点什么，所以我选择了飞行。
I think that you could probably even say that that feeling, that being 11 and not understanding and being scared and confused and frightened, is why everyone was so excited Sunday night. Because we all kind of carried that fear with us. We definitely must have. Because if not, then I don't think Sunday night would have happened.
我认为甚至可以说，那种11岁时不理解、感到恐惧和困惑的感觉，就是为什么每个人在周日晚上都如此兴奋的原因。因为我们都在某种程度上带着那种恐惧。我们肯定一定是带着的。因为如果不是这样，我就不认为周日晚上的事情会发生。
And so I think that this moment wasn't necessarily an end point, but was the closest thing that we had felt. It was this big indicator that there could be an end.
所以我认为这个时刻不一定是一个终点，但却是我们感受到的最接近终点的事情。这是一个巨大的标志，表明可能有一个结束。
Oh, right. Because if you're you, and most of your cognizant life has been different versions of the same situation, which is that we are at war with this sort of shadowy network, I could totally see how it feels like it's never going to end.
哦，没错。因为如果你是你们这一代，你大部分懂事的生活都是同一情况的不同版本，也就是我们正与这个所谓阴暗的网络处于战争状态，我完全能看出为什么这感觉好像永远不会结束。
And that's exactly how it feels. It's kind of neat for me. My little sister-- my mom was pregnant with her on September 11. She was seven months pregnant, I think. And now she's in third grade. I don't know. I really the past couple of days have been thinking about her a lot. And I'm almost really excited for her, because she doesn't know about any of this. She doesn't understand any of this. And for me at least, it was this moment that I realized that maybe Chloe won't have to have the same confusing years as a 12, 13, 14, 15 year old.
而这正是那种感觉。对我来说这挺微妙的。我妹妹——9·11时我妈妈怀着她。我想她当时怀孕七个月。而现在她上三年级了。我不知道。过去几天我真的经常想到她。我甚至为她感到非常兴奋，因为她不知道这一切。她不理解这一切。对我来说，至少，这是我意识到也许克洛伊不必经历同样的那些作为12、13、14、15岁时的困惑岁月的时刻。
Did you feel like, well, maybe she never has to know now?
你是否觉得，好吧，也许她现在不必知道了？
Exactly. And that was a really cool feeling for me.
正是。对我来说这是一种非常酷的感觉。
Did you even know before Sunday night that you were waiting for an end point? Do you know what I'm saying? Like, before the feeling came, did you even know, "Oh, this is the feeling I've wanted to have all this time?"
在周日晚上之前，你甚至知道你在等待一个终点吗？你明白我的意思吗？就像在那种感觉到来之前，你甚至知道，“哦，这就是我一直想要的那种感觉吗？”
It's really interesting, because I don't think that I had. I don't know that I necessarily felt the way that I did until I'm watching 6,000 of my peers in the streets celebrating. But I had no idea.
这真的很有趣，因为我不认为我有过。我不知道在看着6000名同龄人在街上庆祝之前，我是否一定有那种感觉。但我根本不知道。
When I'd asked another student why he and his friends cared so much about what happened Sunday since they were just little kids when September 11 happened-- it didn't happen to them-- he shot back, "No. It didn't happen to you guys. It happened to us."
当我也问另一个学生为什么他和他的朋友们那么关心周日发生的事，因为他们9·11发生时还是小孩子——那并没有发生在他们身上——他反击道：“不。那没有发生在你们身上。它发生在我们身上。”
Sarah Koenig in State College, Pennsylvania.
宾夕法尼亚州州立大学的莎拉·凯尼格报道。
In Egypt, on Monday, the day after President Obama announced Osama bin Laden was killed, out on the street it was kind of a non-event. No demonstrations. Yes, the Muslim Brotherhood issued a statement. Yes, obviously people talked about the news. But that was it. It was a normal work day. Crazy traffic. Lot of smoking. Everybody glued to their cellphones. And for all of us wondering what does the death of Osama bin Laden mean for the Mideast, this was the reaction in the most influential, most populous Arab country in the world. A fourth of all Arabs live in Egypt. Our producer Nancy Updike went by Tahrir Square in the afternoon.
在埃及，周一，也就是奥巴马总统宣布奥萨马·本·拉登被击毙后的第二天，街头基本上什么都没发生。没有示威。是的，穆斯林兄弟会发表了声明。是的，人们显然谈论了这则新闻。但仅此而已。这是个正常的工作日。交通疯狂。很多人抽烟。每个人都盯着自己的手机。对于我们这些想知道奥萨马·本·拉登之死对中东意味着什么的人来说，这就是世界上人口最多、最有影响力的阿拉伯国家的反应。四分之一的阿拉伯人生活在埃及。我们的制片人南希·厄普代克下午去了塔里尔广场。
If anyone in Egypt wanted to mark Osama bin Laden's death publicly or spark a national conversation about it, Tahrir Square would be the place. But the only activity I saw there on the day of the announcement was a man taking a nap on the grass. In Cairo, the conversation is not about bin Laden. It's about something completely different. From the moment I got here, I was hearing the same thing over and over, "I'd love to talk, but I'm on my way to a meeting." Or, "I'm in a meeting. Can I call you back?"
如果埃及有人想公开纪念奥萨马·本·拉登的死亡或引发一场关于此的国家对话，塔里尔广场就是那个地方。但我那天在公告发布时在那里看到的唯一活动是一个人在草地上小睡。在开罗，对话不是关于本·拉登的。而是关于完全不同的事情。从我到这儿的那一刻起，我就不断听到同样的话：“我很想聊，但我正要去开会。”或者，“我正在开会。能稍后回电吗？”
These weren't work meetings. They're the meetings of 82 million people deciding what their country will be. If Egypt had a national sound right now, it would be the sound of chairs scraping into a circle, or maybe the sound right after that.
这些不是工作会议。这是8200万人在决定他们的国家将成为什么样子的会议。如果埃及现在有一种国家声音，那会是椅子被拖到圆圈里的声音，或者可能是那之后发出的声音。
[MALE VOICES ARGUING]
[男性争论的声音]
Arguing. This man is saying, "Why, why, why, why?" He's one of about 15 people in a room forming a new political party. They're figuring out what the party stands for and how it should present itself, right now, in front of me. They've got a name for the party, the Egyptian Social Democratic Party. But what does that mean exactly? The man shouting, "Why," is responding to someone else who is saying, "We're not liberals. We're not calling ourselves liberals."
争论。这个男人正在说，“为什么，为什么，为什么，为什么？”他是房间里大约15个正在组建新政党的人之一。他们正在弄清楚这个党代表什么以及应该如何呈现自己，就在我面前。他们给党取了个名字，埃及社会民主党。但那到底意味着什么？那个大喊“为什么”的男人是在回应另一个人，那个人说：“我们不是自由派。我们不称自己为自由派。”
"What's wrong with liberalism?" the why man wants to know.
“自由主义有什么问题？”那个“为什么男”想知道。
"Liberalism has a taint now," the other guy says. "Some people are equating liberal parties with infidels. I have nothing against liberalism," he adds. "I am a liberal."
“自由主义现在有了污点，”另一个人说。“有些人正在把自由派政党等同于异教徒。我对自由主义没有什么反对意见，”他补充道。“我是一个自由派。”
"And wait, how are we different from other free market parties?" someone else asks.
“等等，我们和其他自由市场政党有什么不同？”另一些人问道。
A man sitting behind the one desk in the room clarifies. "We're somewhere between socialism and liberalism. Free market, but more like France or Germany than America."
坐在房间里唯一一张桌子后面的一个男人澄清道。“我们介于社会主义和自由主义之间。自由市场，但更像法国或德国而不是美国。”
I spent the week going to meetings. They're happening everywhere. This one is 25 men sitting on plastic chairs in a circle out on the sidewalk lecturing each other about politics. I went to another meeting on the AstroTurf deck of a boat on the Nile-- two judges, three religious men, and a DJ, who I think qualifies for the title of Mr. Meeting.
我花了一周时间参加会议。它们到处都在发生。这个是一个由25个男人坐在人行道上的塑料椅子围成一圈，互相进行政治讲座。我去了另一个会议，在尼罗河的一艘船的草皮甲板上——两名法官，三名宗教人士，还有一位DJ，我认为他有资格获得“会议先生”的称号。
[SPEAKING IN ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语发言]
This is [? Gihad ?], a charming, six-foot-tall DJ, music producer, and party boy who was apolitical and, he cheerfully admits, rather debauched under Mubarak's rule. He told an interpreter and me about sleeping until 5:00 PM, going to parties all night. But then he saw friends die in front of him on Tahrir Square. And now he's quit being a DJ. He's living off his savings, and he goes to meetings all day. He starts ticking off his previous 24 hours. Noon prayer, followed by a neighborhood meeting about how to deal with crime. Then on to a seminar about the pros and cons of a parliamentary republic versus a presidential republic. 8:00 PM dinner meeting with friends working on political issues. An 11:00 PM meeting with other activists to nail down the agenda for a meeting the following day. Then at 2:00 AM, a final meeting back in his neighborhood. Four hours sleep. Woke up. Picked up a friend. Drove here.
这是吉哈德，一个迷人的、六英尺高的DJ、音乐制作人和派对男孩，他在穆巴拉克统治下曾不关心政治，而且他愉快地承认，相当放荡。他告诉翻译和我关于他睡到下午5点，整晚去参加派对的事。但后来他在塔里尔广场亲眼目睹了朋友的死亡。现在他不再做DJ了。他靠积蓄生活，整天去参加会议。他开始盘点他过去24小时的时间。正午祈祷，接着是一个关于如何应对犯罪的社区会议。然后去参加一个关于议会制共和国与总统制共和国优缺点的研讨会。晚上8点与从事政治问题的朋友共进晚餐。晚上11点与其他活动家开会确定次日会议的议程。然后凌晨2点，在社区回到家后的最后一次会议。睡了四个小时。醒了。接了个朋友。开车到这里。
My interpreter and I left Mr. Meeting, got off the elevator at the sixth floor of an office building, and headed into a conference room for one last meeting that ended up being pretty mind blowing. At first it looked like a classic corporate gab fest-- fluorescent lit room, about 30 people sitting around a huge oval conference table with croissants and bread sticks in front of them. But this was an assembly of two very different groups, longtime enemies, in fact, sitting face to face to see whether in the new Egypt they'll still be enemies.
我和翻译离开会议先生后，在办公大楼的六楼走出电梯，进入一个会议室参加最后一次会议，结果令人大开眼界。起初它看起来像一个经典的商业会议——荧光灯照亮的房间，大约30人坐在一个巨大的椭圆形会议桌旁，面前摆着羊角面包和面包条。但这实际上是两个截然不同的团体的集会，事实上是长期以来的敌人，面对面坐着，看看在新的埃及他们是否还会继续是敌人。
On one side was writers, journalists, editors, left-wing Egyptians actively working to keep Egypt secular. On the other side, current and former members of the [? Gama'ah ?] [? Is-lamiyah, ?] an Egyptian Islamist organization that spent years murdering both foreign tourists and Egyptians. They went after policemen and politicians, including the president of Egypt. They were part of the plot that killed Anwar Sadat. The men sitting here have served decades in Egypt's prisons. The Gama'ah Is-lamiyah also targeted Egyptian intellectuals, exactly the sort of people they're now sitting across from.
一边是作家、记者、编辑，积极致力于保持埃及世俗化的左翼埃及人。另一边是埃及伊斯兰组织的现任和前任成员，该组织花了多年时间杀害外国游客和埃及人。他们追杀警察和政客，包括埃及总统。他们是刺杀安瓦尔·萨达特阴谋的一部分。坐在这里的人已经在埃及的监狱里服刑了几十年。该组织还针对埃及知识分子，正是他们现在坐在对面的人。
The Gama'ah Is-lamiyah started off the meeting the way they had to, by reiterating the fact that they publicly renounced violence 14 years ago. And they still renounce it today. "No one is forcing us to say this," said Nageh Ibrahim, a thin man with a long white beard, the Gama'ah Is-lamiyah leader who spoke most often.
该组织以他们必须采取的方式开始了会议，重申了他们14年前公开放弃暴力这一事实。直到今天他们依然放弃暴力。“没有人强迫我们说这些，”纳格·易卜拉欣说，一个留着长长白胡子的瘦削男人，他是经常发言的该组织领导人。
He said, "Mubarak is gone. We can say what we want. And we're saying the same thing today we've been saying for years-- no violence."
他说，“穆巴拉克已经不在了。我们可以说我们想说的话。我们今天说的和我们多年来一直在说的是同一件事——没有暴力。”
After 15 minutes of back and forth about that, one of the journalists suddenly shifted the conversation with a quiet question. "What's your position on art?"
在进行了15分钟关于此的来回辩论后，一位记者突然用一个安静的问题转换了对话。“你们对艺术的立场是什么？”
For years, Islamic extremists have preached a sort of cultural anorexia, no poetry, music, dance. And in this meeting, once art came up, it took over the conversation. The secularists wanted to know, "What art is OK in your view?" "Does painting have a place in Egypt, sculpture?" "How about theatre, movies?" "Do you believe in such a thing as Islamic art and non-Islamic art?" "Would you ban any art if you could?" The conversation went from chilly and polite to blunt. One of the secularists, a famous novelist, [? Yousef ?] [? al-Kayyid ?] said, "We're not here so you can reassure us. We're here to find out what you really believe."
多年来，伊斯兰极端分子一直宣扬一种文化厌食症，没有诗歌，没有音乐，没有舞蹈。在这个会议上，艺术一旦被提出来，它就占据了对话的主导地位。世俗主义者想知道，“在你们看来什么样的艺术是可以的？”“绘画在埃及有一席之地吗，雕塑？”“戏剧，电影呢？”“你们相信有所谓的伊斯兰艺术和非伊斯兰艺术吗？”“如果可以的话，你们会禁止任何艺术吗？”对话从冷淡礼貌变得生硬。一位世俗主义者，著名小说家优素福·凯耶德说，“我们在这里不是为了让你们安抚我们。我们在这里是为了找出你们真正相信什么。”
For the next hour, the secularists and the men from the Gama'ah Is-lamiyah have a surreal conversation, the kind that happens when people with profound differences do manage to speak civilly and honestly with each other. The two groups argued, quoted poetry, brought up specific Arab pop stars and their videos, and talked about the evolution of Islamic scholarship on the subject of whether it's OK to paint or sculpt a person. The short version, according to the head of Gama'ah Is-lamiyah, first, no. Then, yes. And now, it's probably OK. Photography? Fine. Ballet? Not OK. No, there isn't Islamic literature and non-Islamic literature. Literature is literature. We like music-- well, some music. It can't be sexy. We used to sing ourselves and put on little plays when we were in prison, to entertain ourselves.
接下来的一个小时，世俗主义者和该组织的人进行了超现实的对话，这种对话只有在拥有深刻分歧的人们确实能够文明且诚实地交谈时才会发生。两组人争论，引用诗歌，提到特定的阿拉伯流行歌星和他们的视频，并讨论了关于是否可以画人像或雕塑的人像的伊斯兰学术进化。简短的版本是，根据该组织负责人的说法，首先，不可以。然后，可以。现在，这可能没问题。摄影？很好。芭蕾？不行。不，没有伊斯兰文学和非伊斯兰文学。文学就是文学。我们喜欢音乐——好吧，一些音乐。它不能是性感的。我们在监狱里时，为了自娱自乐，我们自己唱歌并排演一些小短剧。
And we read. One of the Gama'ah Is-lamiyah men said, "I really like the writing of Naghib Mahfouz. Since reading him, I don't read any other novels. I read all his books when I was in prison, and I related to them."
我们阅读。其中一名男子说，“我真的很喜欢纳吉布·马哈福兹的作品。自从读了他的作品，我就不读其他小说了。我在监狱时读了他所有的书，我与它们产生了共鸣。”
This was an olive branch of sorts. Mahfouz is Egypt's most celebrated writer, proudly secular, who was stabbed in an assassination attempt by an Islamist militant after Gama'ah Is-lamiyah put him on a hit list.
这是一种橄榄枝。马哈福兹是埃及最著名的作家，他自豪地世俗，在被该组织列入暗杀名单后，曾遭到一名伊斯兰激进分子的暗杀尝试。
Later in the meeting, one of the Gama'ah leaders, Nageh Ibrahim, said, "Look, we may differ with you about art. But Gama'ah Is-lamiyah will not burn art, will not destroy, will not ban. I could disagree with you about literature, art, or politics. That doesn't mean I would be violent against you or attack you. No. We fight thought with thought."
会议晚些时候，该组织领导人纳格·易卜拉欣说，“看，我们可能在艺术上与你们有分歧。但我们不会焚烧艺术，不会破坏，不会禁止。我可以在文学、艺术或政治上与你意见不一。这并不意味着我会对你们施暴或攻击你们。不。我们用思想对抗思想。”
Maybe promising not to stab someone seems a little too basic to be a bragging point, but in this conversation, it was part of a bigger statement by the Gama'ah Is-lamiyah. "We want to be part of the real Egypt, not a fantasy that we try to create by killing people."
也许承诺不刺伤某人听起来太基本了，不足以成为炫耀的资本，但在这次对话中，这是该组织更大声明的一部分。“我们想成为真正埃及的一部分，而不是我们通过杀人试图创造的幻想。”
The Gama'ah Is-lamiyah is in this meeting because it was the first violent Islamist group to not only renounce violence, but also publicly apologize and say what they did was wrong. Their leadership then spent years writing a detailed, mutil-volume refutation of their former beliefs, including a direct challenge to al-Qaeda's argument that America is a nation of infidels who deserve to be killed. Gama'ah Is-lamiyah said, "No, that's not true." And they quoted the First Amendment of the US Constitution guaranteeing freedom of religion in their rebuttal.
该组织参加这次会议是因为它是第一个不仅放弃暴力，而且公开道歉并说他们所做的是错误的暴力伊斯兰组织。他们的领导层随后花了多年时间写了一部详细的、多卷本的对其前信仰的驳斥，包括对基地组织关于美国是一个值得被杀死的异教徒国家的论点的直接挑战。该组织说，“不，那不是真的。”并且他们在反驳中引用了美国宪法第一修正案中关于宗教自由的条款。
All of which brings me to Osama bin Laden. Egyptian thinkers provided the inspiration for al-Qaeda. Al-Qaeda's modern ideological underpinnings are mostly from Egyptian Islamist writers, especially Sayyid Qutb. Bin Laden's second in command, Ayman al-Zawahiri is Egyptian, and he started reading Qutb as a teenager. One of bin Laden's professors at university was Qutb's brother. The modern phenomenon of violent political Islam has its roots in Egypt. And, in terms of ideology and some key members, so does al-Qaeda. But what does that mean for Egypt today?
所有这一切都让我联想到奥萨马·本·拉登。埃及思想家为基地组织提供了灵感。基地组织的现代意识形态基础大多来自埃及伊斯兰作家，特别是赛义德·库特布。本·拉登的二号人物艾曼·扎瓦希里是埃及人，他十几岁时就开始阅读库特布的作品。本·拉登在大学的一位教授是库特布的兄弟。现代暴力政治伊斯兰现象的根源在埃及。而且，在意识形态和一些关键成员方面，基地组织也是如此。但这对于今天的埃及意味着什么？
I had a guess, and I ran it by the leader of Gama'ah Is-lamiyah, Sheikh Karam Zuhdi, the day after the meeting at his home.
我有了一个猜测，我在会议次日在他家里和该组织领导人卡拉姆·祖赫迪进行了交流。
It seems to me that Ayman Zawahiri and bin Laden and al-Qaeda, they're following ideas that came from Egypt 50 years ago. And Egypt, itself, has moved on.
在我看来，艾曼·扎瓦希里、本·拉登和基地组织，他们正在遵循50年前来自埃及的想法。而埃及本身已经向前迈进了。
[SPEAKING IN ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语发言]
I think you're absolutely right. These are the ideas of the '50s and the '60s and the '70s. Egypt has overcome that, has gone through other phases. Like I said, the youth on Tahrir, they brought down A whole regime just with the strength of the word and maybe a stone.
我认为你是绝对正确的。这些是50年代、60年代和70年代的想法。埃及已经克服了这一点，已经经历了其他阶段。就像我说的，塔里尔广场上的年轻人，他们仅凭文字的力量，或许还有一块石头，就推翻了整个政权。
Do you ever worry that it could come back in Egypt-- violence in the name of Islam?
你是否担心它会在埃及卷土重来——以伊斯兰之名进行的暴力？
[SPEAKING IN ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语发言]
I feel it won't come back, God willing.
我觉得它不会回来，上帝保佑。
Egyptians right now are in love with Egypt. Egypt is what they want to talk about, not bin Laden. And that includes groups like Gama'ah Is-lamiyah that used to have a similar ideology. The Gama'ah Is-lamiyah leaders are doing the same thing other Egyptians are doing, sitting down at tables with croissants and bread sticks, and talking about the future of their country.
埃及人现在热爱埃及。埃及是他们想谈论的，而不是本·拉登。这包括像该组织这样曾经拥有类似意识形态的团体。该组织的领导人正在做其他埃及人正在做的事情，坐在摆着羊角面包和面包条的桌旁，谈论他们国家的未来。
Nancy Updike in Cairo.
开罗的南希·厄普代克报道。
Here in United States this week, despite the President calling for a moment of unity, democracy still seems to meet people at each other's throats.
本周在美国，尽管总统呼吁团结一致，民主似乎仍然让人们互相掐住喉咙。
Take this incident in Arizona. This was not big news at all. The Tucson Unified School District is considering something that you wouldn't think, from the outside, would be something that people could get quite this mad about. The issue was whether the Mexican-American studies program in high school will be turned from a core credit to an elective. That's it. People who oppose that change say that if it's going to be an elective, then the many at-risk kids who do well in that course, whose GPAs are helped by that course, who basically are the target population for that course, they will never take the course. So the course will miss its target population.
看看亚利桑那州的这次事件。这根本不是什么大新闻。图森联合学区正在考虑一件从外部看你可能不会觉得人们会如此愤怒的事情。问题是高中里的墨西哥裔美国人研究课程是否会从核心学分转为选修课。就是这样。反对这一改变的人说，如果它要成为选修课，那么许多在那门课程中表现良好、GPA因该课程而提高、基本上是该课程目标群体的处于风险中的孩子，他们将永远不会选修这门课。所以这门课将失去它的目标群体。
So Monday this week, school board's going to discuss this. And this middle school teacher named Sarah Bromer, from this charter school, goes to the school board meeting with a tape recorder. And she sits in the second row next to a seat that has this piece of paper on it that says, "Reserved."
所以本周一，校董会要讨论这个问题。这位来自特许学校的中学老师莎拉·布罗默带着录音机去参加了校董会会议。她坐在第二排，旁边的一个座位上放着一张写着“已预留”的纸条。
So the meeting is packed, over a hundred people in the room. And from the beginning of this meeting, there's heckling. Somebody calls the school board president bandito. There's chanting. The school board decides to hear 30 minutes of testimony from the public on this issue. And then the school board wants to cut it off. But people keep standing to speak. So somebody stands up, they try to speak, they're escorted out by police. Then an older woman, a teacher at Pima Community College named Lupe Castillo, she gets up.
所以会议座无虚席，房里有超过一百人。从会议一开始，就有嘲弄声。有人称校董会主席为强盗。有人在喊口号。校董会决定听取公众对此问题的30分钟证词。然后校董会想切断它。但人们不断站起来发言。所以有人站起来，他们试图发言，被警察护送出去。然后一位老太太，皮马社区学院的老师卢佩·卡斯蒂略，她站了起来。
And I will read to you the Letter from Birmingham Jail by Martin Luther King. This is what you need to hear. You need to understand and respect.
我将为你们朗读马丁·路德·金的《伯明翰监狱书信》。这是你们需要听到的。你们需要理解和尊重。
The police move in to arrest her. And then things go kind of crazy. The crowd starts chanting. People start standing on their chairs.
警察介入逮捕她。然后事情变得有点疯狂。人群开始高喊。人们开始站在椅子上。
Leave Lupe alone!
放开卢佩！
At this point, the teacher who was recording this thing you're hearing right now, Sarah Bromer, says there are all these students in the room. Suddenly they show up-- 10 of them with white T-shirts and duct tape over their mouths. The police then move like a wave across the room, flushing out Lupe and lots of the protesters, and most of the media, actually. Sarah, who is recording this, ducks between the chairs, and then she sees down there between the chairs the woman who had moved into that seat next to her, that reserved seat, who turns out to be a petite woman in conservative, professional clothes. Sarah works her way back over to her seat next to the woman.
此时，正在录制你现在听到的这段内容的老师，莎拉·布罗默，说房间里有所有这些学生。突然他们出现了——10个人，穿着白T恤，嘴上贴着胶带。警察随后像波浪一样在房间里移动，清理出卢佩和许多抗议者，事实上还有大部分媒体。正在录制的莎拉躲在椅子之间，然后她在身边的椅子下面看到那个移到她旁边座位的女人，那个预留座位，结果是一个穿着保守、职业服装的娇小女性。莎拉挤回到那个女人旁边的座位上。
Why are you here tonight?
你今晚为什么在这里？
Oh, I just came to observe democracy a little bit. But I'm feeling kind of weird. It's a little too loud to me.
哦，我只是来看看民主。但我感觉有点怪。对我来说这太吵了。
Where are you from?
你从哪里来？
I'm from Iran.
我来自伊朗。
From Iran?
来自伊朗？
Yes. I'm not a citizen yet. A permanent resident of the United States. I just wanted to see how they talk to each other. This is just so crazy, man. After 12 years in the United States, I don't think I still exactly get it. Because mostly when I watch things on TV, things are more calm. But now it's a little too rowdy and scary, and both sides yell at each other a little bit.
是的。我还没成为公民。是美国的永久居民。我只是想看看他们是如何交谈的。这太疯狂了，伙计。在美国待了12年，我想我还是不完全明白。因为大多数时候我看电视时，事情比较平静。但现在这有点太吵闹和吓人了，双方都在互相大吼大叫。
I saw you at one point crawling along the floor right when it got really crazy. I saw you kind of crawling along. Were you frightened?
我看到你有一次在事情变得非常疯狂时沿着地板爬行。我看到你有点在爬。你被吓坏了吗？
I'm not the most brave person on the face of planet, and I sort of avoid conflict usually. Somehow I didn't have this opinion about the United States. I didn't think this happens in the United States. I thought it happens elsewhere.
我不是地球上最勇敢的人，我通常会避免冲突。不知何故，我对美国没有这种看法。我没想到这会发生在美国。我以为这发生在其他地方。
Well, it hasn't gotten violent yet.
嗯，还没发生暴力。
No, no.
不，不。
Hopefully it won't.
希望不会。
I got a headache though. I think I'm nervous.
不过我头疼。我想我紧张。
At one point, the Iranian woman asked Sarah, "OK, if this is a democracy, and if you can actually vote out these people if you don't like them, why is everybody being so rude? Why are they yelling so much?" It's a good question.
有一次，那个伊朗女人问莎拉，“好，如果这是一个民主国家，如果你真的可以在不喜欢的情况下把这些人选下去，为什么每个人都这么粗鲁？为什么他们喊得这么大声？”这是一个好问题。
Well, coming up, when everything in your life depends on a political event that the political world ignores. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International when our program continues.
好了，稍后，当你的生活中一切都取决于一个政治世界所忽视的政治事件时。一分钟后，来自芝加哥公共广播电台和公共广播国际公司的节目继续播出。
It's This American Life , I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our show, of course, we choose a theme. This week the theme is, "This Week." We are spending the hour hearing about large things and very small things that happened these past seven days.
这是《美国生活》，我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，当然，我们都会选择一个主题。本周的主题是：“这一周”。我们花一小时听关于过去七天里发生的大事和非常小的事。
Is this a good time to talk?
现在说话方便吗？
Yeah, if you don't mind me packing.
是的，如果你不介意我打包的话。
Sunday, in Oakland, California, Shirley Everett-Dicko was closing up Charcoal Park, which was a very hard-to-describe combination store, African American history museum, community center where kids hung out and came for movies and pizza Friday nights. Shirley has had the place for two years. She's been waiting for a miracle that has not come yet to help pay the rent. And she said on Sunday that lots of people driving by saw the moving trucks and people carrying stuff out and chose that moment to stop in.
周日，在加利福尼亚州奥克兰，雪莉·埃弗雷特-迪科正在关闭木炭公园，那是一个很难描述的综合商店、非裔美国人历史博物馆、社区中心，孩子们在这里聚会，周五晚上来看电影和吃披萨。雪莉经营这个地方已经两年了。她一直在等待一个尚未到来的奇迹来帮助支付租金。她在周日说，很多开车经过的人看到了搬家卡车和搬东西的人，于是选择在那一刻停下来。
Now that they feel this activity, they think they're coming to shop, right? And I'm like, "I'm leaving now." "No, I've been meaning to come here." I said, "Well, that's part of the problem." I hear everybody keep saying you were going to come here. You never did.
现在他们感觉到这种活动，他们以为他们来这里购物，对吧？我说，“我正要走。”“不，我一直打算来这里的。”我说，“好吧，这就是问题的一部分。”我听到每个人都在说你打算来这里。你从没来过。
This looked like such a nice store. I kept meaning to stop in.
这看起来是个不错的店。我一直打算停下来。
Yeah, we've been meaning to. I drive by it all the time. Now you come over the day I'm packing up to leave. We've had a lot of that.
是啊，我们一直打算来。我总是开车经过这里。现在你却在我打包离开的那天过来。我们这种情况经历得太多了。
Does that closet creep you out?
那个衣柜让你毛骨悚然吗？
Yeah, actually it really does, and the other one doesn't look like it.
是啊，真的，另一个看起来没那样。
Yeah, it looks like someone hung themselves in there.
是啊，看起来好像有人在里面上吊了。
I know.
我知道。
On the other side of the country on Saturday, it was moving day for Gabe and Kevin, boyfriends moving in together. Neither of them had ever done this-- had a boyfriend and moved in with him, ever.
在周六国家的另一边，那是盖比和凯文的搬家日，男朋友搬到一起住。他们谁都没做过这种事——有过男朋友并搬到一起，从来没有。
Yeah, I feel like I've always seen friends do this.
是啊，我觉得我总是看到朋友做这件事。
Yeah.
是啊。
And it was always like, oh, I don't know if it'll ever happen for me or if I'll ever have that experience or anything. So now that I am, I'm like, oh.
而且总是觉得，哦，我不知道这是否会发生在我身上，或者我是否会有那种经历之类的。所以现在我正在经历，我心想，哦。
Well, today is Wednesday, and later this evening, there's an Elton John concert in La Crosse, Wisconsin that my girlfriend Roz and I will be attending with my parents, my brother and sister, and possibly my pastor.
嗯，今天是周三，今天晚上晚些时候，在威斯康星州拉克罗斯有一场埃尔顿·约翰的音乐会，我和我的女友罗兹将和我父母、兄弟姐妹，可能还有我们的牧师一起参加。
Eric and Roz are 21 and 23 in Stevens Point, Wisconsin.
埃里克和罗兹在威斯康星州史蒂文斯波因特，分别是21岁和23岁。
And it is at this concert where we intend to tell my parents that we plan on moving in together.
就是在这次音乐会上，我们打算告诉父母我们计划搬到一起住。
And what do you think the reaction is going to be?
你认为反应会是什么样的？
I'm not really optimistic about it, I guess. They're a very Christian couple of people whom I love, I really love. But--
我想我不怎么乐观。他们是一对非常虔诚的基督徒，我爱他们，我真的很爱。但是——
Previously he's made mention to them this could be a possibility in the future. And what his mother's reaction was was that-- I believe the words were, "God is not the only one judging you." Is that correct, Eric?
之前他提到过这在未来可能是一种可能性。而他母亲的反应是——我相信她的话是，“上帝不是唯一一个审判你的人。”是这样吗，埃里克？
So they've been prepping. Eric made a list of talking points-- what he figured his parents would say, how he would respond. And Thursday, the day after the concert, I checked in with them again to see how it went. Roz said that it was hard to enjoy Elton John, she was so stressed out about this conversation they were going to have, which unfortunately, they did not start until midnight-- that wasn't the original plan-- until midnight in his parents house, before hitting the road to return to Stevens Point.
所以他们一直在做准备。埃里克列出了一份谈话要点清单——他预想父母会说什么，他会如何回应。周四，音乐会过后的那天，我再次联系了他们，看看进展如何。罗兹说很难享受埃尔顿·约翰的演出，因为他们要进行的这次谈话让她压力很大，不幸的是，他们直到午夜才开始——这不是最初的计划——直到午夜在他父母家，在出发返回史蒂文斯波因特之前。
We were standing in the kitchen. And his mom and dad were just thanking me for coming. And they were so happy that I was able to experience the show with their family. And I'm just like, my stomach is in knots. And his mother is such a gracious woman. Here she is like, "Oh, do you guys need anything for the trip? Some food?" She's packing up tons of food for us, and she's like, "Let me make you a sandwich." And I'm thinking, "You're going to want to retract those statements once I tell you I'm going to be living with your son."
我们站在厨房里。他的父母只是在感谢我的到来。他们很高兴我能和他们的家人一起体验演出。我的胃像打结了一样。而他的母亲是一位如此优雅的女性。她在这里说，“哦，你们旅行需要什么吗？带些食物？”她为我们打包了大量的食物，她说，“让我为你做个三明治。”而我在想，“一旦我告诉你我要和你儿子同居，你会想收回这些话的。”
So they finally broke the news. They want to move in together. They each gave a little talk about why, and waited.
所以他们终于宣布了这个消息。他们想搬到一起住。他们每个人都做了一番关于原因的小演讲，然后等待。
Eric's mom just said, "OK." And she just kind of paused, and her response was, "Well, you're both adults. And we see." She didn't really say, "We understand," or "We accept that." But she's like, "We see."
埃里克的母亲只是说，“好。”她停顿了一下，她的回答是，“好吧，你们都是成年人了。我们知道了。”她并没有真正说，“我们理解，”或者“我们接受这一点。”但她说，“我们知道了。”
So Eric, it seems like this went very, very differently than you thought it would. It seems like your mom was lovely.
所以埃里克，看来这和你预想的完全不同。看来你妈妈很可爱。
Yeah, she really was. My dad was all right too.
是啊，她真的是。我爸爸也还好。
But during our interview, Eric's mom left him a long voicemail that he discovered when he got out of the studio. It is not over. His mom thinks they're rushing into it. It could ruin their relationship. June 1, moving day, is coming up very, very soon.
但在我们采访期间，埃里克的母亲给他留了一条长长的语音留言，他在走出录音室时发现了。这还没完。他妈妈认为他们太仓促了。这可能会毁了他们的关系。6月1日，搬家日，马上就要到了。
I'll get that there, buddy.
我会拿那个，伙计。
On Monday of this week, in South Portland, Maine, the two grave diggers at the Mount Pleasant Cemetery, Eugene Rand and Bill True-- they're also best friends by the way-- held a work stoppage, and then ended the work stoppage. That's what you're hearing right now. The work stoppage was to protest the fact that the 137-year-old cemetery was finally going to modernize. They were going to finally buy a machine to dig graves, a backhoe, to replace one of the two guys.
本周一，在缅因州南波特兰，圣普莱森特公墓的两个掘墓人，尤金·兰德和比尔·特鲁——顺便说一句，他们也是最好的朋友——举行了一次停工，然后结束了停工。这就是你现在听到的。停工是为了抗议这座有137年历史的公墓终于要现代化了。他们终于要买一台挖掘坟墓的机器，反铲挖掘机，来代替两人中的一个。
And on Monday, the cemetery's president met with two guys and told them that he had decided to keep them both until the end of June, and then he would decide about the backhoe. Satisfied, they went back to digging. Bill says that the whole problem is this new manager that the cemetery has brought in.
周一，公墓主席与两人会面，告诉他们他决定保留两人直到6月底，然后他会决定关于挖掘机的事。感到满意，他们回去继续挖掘。比尔说整个问题是公墓新带来的这个经理。
I enjoy working here. I like doing this. That dude over there, he's got to go. He just needs to change his attitude a little bit. Show a little respect to the guys that do actually do the work here. And I guess not treat us like a couple peons that don't know anything. Yeah, I really hope things work out.
我喜欢在这里工作。我喜欢做这个。那个家伙，他得走人。他只是需要改变一下他的态度。对真正做这里工作的人表现出一点尊重。而不是像对待一对什么都不懂的苦力那样对待我们。是的，我真的希望事情能解决。
It could take all day to dig a grave by hand. They hit rocks. It's hard to keep the sides straight and square. It's hard work. And here's something that the reporter who talked to these guys, Clay Bolton, learned that I had no idea about.
手工挖掘一个坟墓可能要花一整天。他们会碰到石头。很难保持侧面笔直且方正。这是艰苦的工作。这是和这些人交谈的记者克莱·博尔顿学到的一些我以前完全不知道的事情。
That whole cliche about six feet under? Never. Even in the old days, I guess, maybe they went six feet under. No.
关于六英尺下的那种陈词滥调？从来没有。即使在过去，我想，也许他们确实挖到六英尺深。不。
So if it's not six feet under, how deep do you guys get?
所以如果不是六英尺下，你们挖多深？
Four feet.
四英尺。
Just below the frost line, average four feet.
刚好在冻土层以下，平均四英尺。
No one has ever been buried six feet.
没有人被埋在六英尺深处。
That's an old cliche. It really is.
那是一个古老的陈词滥调。确实是。
It's just an old saying, really.
那真的只是一个古老的说法。
The first foot is real easy, Eugene says. The second foot gets tough. Your third foot is killing. The fourth foot, you're ready to quit. And squaring off the bottom, that can be half a day by itself, he says.
第一英尺真的很容易，尤金说。第二英尺变得艰难。第三英尺会让你累死。第四英尺，你准备放弃了。而把底部挖平，那可能本身就需要半天，他说。
You really didn't see it in the headlines, but all this week, people across the South were still dealing with the aftermath of last week's tornadoes. That's not over, not even close. Official estimates are that there were at least 300 tornadoes. At least 329 people have died across seven states, according to the Associated Press. And a week in, you would think that there would be this agreed-on set of facts. Not so. David Kestenbaum learned this down in Tuscaloosa, Alabama.
你真的没在头条新闻里看到，但这整个星期，南方各地的人们仍在处理上周龙卷风的余波。这还没结束，甚至相差甚远。官方估计至少有300场龙卷风。据美联社报道，七个州至少有329人死亡。一周过去了，你以为会有一套公认的事实。并非如此。大卫·凯斯滕鲍姆在阿拉巴马州塔斯卡卢萨了解到了这一点。
It's understandable that after a monster tornado churns through your town, picking up cars and chewing up houses, even a week later, there's going to be some new piece of unsettling news.
可以理解，在巨大的龙卷风席卷你的城镇，卷走汽车并摧毁房屋之后，即使是一周后，也会有一些新的令人不安的新闻。
We started getting some calls that a lake-- actually kind of a pond in a development, older neighborhood that had been largely destroyed-- that they had drained it and found five bodies in the bottom of the lake.
我们开始接到一些电话说一个湖——其实是一个开发区里的一个池塘，老社区，大部分已经被摧毁了——他们已经把它抽干，在湖底发现了五具尸体。
This is Doug Ray, editor of the local paper, The Tuscaloosa News . The thing about the bodies in the lake story, though, it just wasn't true. Neither were the others.
这是当地报纸《塔斯卡卢萨新闻》的编辑道格·雷。不过关于湖中尸体的故事，根本不是真的。其他的谣言也不是真的。
The first rumors we started hearing were Sunday afternoon.
我们开始听到第一个谣言是在周日下午。
One rumor, that the former mayor had been killed. Not true. In fact, he'd stopped by the newspaper in person. Another, that the hospital morgue had a 150 bodies in it. also not true. It only holds six.
一个谣言，前市长被杀。不真实。事实上，他亲自到过报社。另一个，医院停尸房里有150具尸体。也不真实。它只容纳六具。
Wait, do y'all want to go through? I made a list.
等等，你们想过一遍吗？我列了个清单。
This week, Doug started a new beat, the Rumors Beat. And he put Stephanie Taylor on it, who started making a list.
这周，道格开始了新的报道任务，谣言报道。他让斯蒂芬妮·泰勒负责，她开始列清单。
The mayor has allegedly ordered all cops and firefighters to shoot every dog they come across. This is a really grim rumor that we've heard, is that there were several children in the Chuck E. Cheese-- it's a pizza place with games and stuff-- that were killed and were not pulled out. And I know for a fact that was not the case, because that's where I went. I was out there five minutes after it happened. There was nobody in that building at the time. I don't even think they were open. And there's a few others that I need to put on the list. It's wild. It's gotten out of control at this point.
市长据称命令所有警察和消防员射杀他们遇到的每一只狗。这是我们听到的一个非常严峻的谣言，说是Chuck E. Cheese——那是一个有游戏和东西的披萨店——里面有几个孩子被杀，没被拉出来。我知道那不是事实，因为我去了那里。事情发生后五分钟我就在那儿了。当时那栋楼里没人。我觉得他们甚至都没营业。还有一些其他人我需要列入清单。这太疯狂了。目前已经失控了。
Down here right now, it's hard to say what's a crazy rumor and what's a tip worth following up on, because a freaking tornado tore through town. Everything seems crazy. It's like, if that can happen, who knows what's true? Stephanie had two stories on the front page the day I visited, one incredible one about a couple, Amy Hall and Keith Matthews. I went to visit them at a shelter. Amy says when the tornado hit, she was at home talking to Keith on the phone who was telling her, "Look out. I think the tornado is headed your way."
现在这里很难说什么是疯狂的谣言，什么是值得追踪的线索，因为该死的龙卷风撕裂了城镇。一切看起来都很疯狂。就像，如果那都能发生，谁知道什么是真的？我访问那天，斯蒂芬妮在头版有两篇报道，其中一篇关于一对夫妇，艾米·霍尔和基思·马修斯的报道非常不可思议。我去收容所看望他们。艾米说龙卷风来袭时，她在家正和基思通电话，基思告诉她，“小心。我想龙卷风正朝你那边过去。”
And I didn't take him serious at all. Then my power went out. So I'm like, OK. He said, "Well, just look outside and see if you see it." And I looked outside, and it was right in the street in front of the house.
我根本没当真。然后我的电断了。所以我心想，好吧。他说，“好吧，只要往外看，看看能不能看到它。”我往外看，它就在房子前面的街道上。
The tornado was.
龙卷风。
The tornado was. And it seemed like it was just sitting there waiting to see, you know, for me to open the door, to say, "OK, well, you know I'm here. So I'm going to destroy your stuff." That's how it was just sitting there, turning. So I closed the door. I locked the door like that was going to stop it, and I grabbed Kristen, my 10 month old, off the couch. As soon as I was running through the little hallway to get to the bedroom where the kids were, the house just came up. It just rose up in the air.
龙卷风。它看起来就像坐在那里等着看，你知道，等着我打开门，说，“好吧，你知道我在这儿了。所以我打算摧毁你的东西。”它就是那样坐在那里，旋转着。所以我关上门。我锁上门，好像那样就能阻止它，我把我的10个月大的克里斯汀从沙发上抓起来。我刚跑过小走廊想去孩子们所在的卧室，房子就起来了。它直接升到了空中。
The tornado lifted the house with her and her three kids in it.
龙卷风把房子连同她和她的三个孩子一起举了起来。
And we were we were floating, like, we couldn't move. We were just floating.
我们我们浮着，就像，我们动弹不得。我们只是在漂浮。
What was it like being in the house when it is in the air?
当房子在空中时，在里面是什么感觉？
It was like a movie, something you would see on a movie. We were floating like astronauts. And I was holding Kristen, and I was still on my phone with Keith. So he could hear everything.
就像电影一样，你在电影里看到的那种东西。我们像宇航员一样在漂浮。我抱着克里斯汀，我还在和基思通话。所以他能听到一切。
I just heard a bunch of racket and stuff going everywhere, and the phone came disconnected. I just tried to get to them fast as I could.
我只是听到一阵嘈杂声，东西到处乱飞，电话断线了。我只是尽我所能快点去找他们。
We was just shifting wherever the wind blew us, that's where we were going. And it just slammed us. We was a block and a half over from where our house actually was when we got out.
我们只是随着风吹的方向移动，那就是我们要去的地方。然后它猛地把我们摔在地上。我们出来时，离我们房子原来的位置有一个半街区远。
The tornado picked the house up and moved it a block and a half?
龙卷风把房子举起来移动了一个半街区？
Yes. It moved us a block and a half.
是的。它把我们移动了一个半街区。
Everyone survived. Her littlest son was on his mattress and slept through the whole thing. A relief worker told me she met a kid who said, "I flew in the sky like paper." So when you hear something like five bodies, 36 bodies found at the bottom of the lake, your response isn't, "No way." It's, "How awful." Here's Stephanie with the newspaper.
每个人都活下来了。她最小的儿子躺在他的床垫上，全程都在睡觉。一名救援人员告诉我，她遇到一个孩子说，“我像纸一样飞在天空中。”所以当你听到什么五具尸体，在湖底发现36具尸体时，你的反应不是，“没那回事。”而是，“多可怕啊。”这是带着报纸的斯蒂芬妮。
I believed a few of them at first. I even wrote in a story that a man had been killed in a tobacco convenience store, and people were walking over his body to get cigarettes and soft drinks and things. Because when I was out on the street, I heard that from at least four people. And one was an official person, and he was repeating this as if it was truth. And I came back here, and I checked with my boss. And he said, "Go with it." And I wrote it.
起初我信了其中的几个。我甚至写了一篇报道，说一个男人在一家烟草便利店被杀，人们从他尸体上走过去买香烟、软饮料之类的东西。因为当我走在街上时，我从至少四个人那里听到了这件事。其中一个是官方人员，他重复这件事就好像它是真的一样。我回到这儿，和我老板核实了一下。他说，“写吧。”我就写了。
And the more I've thought about it, the more unlikely it seems. But on the first day, when there was so much pandemonium, and so much information coming from everywhere, it seemed like something that could've happened and probably did happen, to me. And the longer I've had to stew on it, I don't think that it did, but--
我越想它，它看起来越不像真的。但在第一天，当有那么多混乱，而且信息从四面八方涌来时，这对我来说看起来就像是一件可能发生且确实发生了的事情。但我思考的时间越长，我就越觉得它没发生，但——
A lot of these seem to be also-- about the bodies. Like, there was a house there that's not there, and where are the people? It's kind of that question, because you don't always get the body, right? It's like, where did the people go? Where did the house go? Where did life go?
其中很多似乎也都是——关于尸体。就像，那里有一栋房子，现在不在了，人呢？这有点像那个问题，因为你并不总是能找到尸体，对吧？就像，人们去哪了？房子去哪了？生命去哪了？
Right. And I think a lot of people have called us to ask about whether there were 36 bodies in the bottom of this lake. And they argue with us when we tell them, no. That's not happened. They did not drain the lake. We've seen it. It's still there. There's still water in the lake. The mayor told that they did not drain the lake. And they argue and say, "They did. They did drain the lake, and they did find these bodies in there." And then, I mean what do you say back to that? It seems like they want to believe it, in a way. Maybe because that would kind of resolve where these people are, rather than not knowing where they are. I don't know. I don't know what makes people want to believe it. It's just-- I don't know.
没错。而且我想很多人打电话问我们是否在湖底发现了36具尸体。当我们告诉他们没有时，他们和我们争论。那没发生。他们没抽干湖水。我们看到了。它还在那儿。湖里还有水。市长说他们没抽干湖水。他们争论说，“抽干了。他们确实抽干了湖水，他们确实在里面发现了这些尸体。”然后，我的意思是你能回答什么？看起来他们想相信这一点，以某种方式。也许是因为那样会解决这些人去哪了的问题，而不是不知道他们在哪。我不知道。我不知道是什么让人想相信它。只是——我不知道。
One thing, I get home and I'll turn on the television and turn on my computer and have it in my lap, and just read this stuff all day long. And in the car on the way home, I'm listening to the radio station, and they've been going constantly, 24 hours a day since this happened. People are calling in, "We need these items." That kind of stuff. And I can't seem to turn it off. And maybe I should. But I think a lot of people are like me. And that might be where a lot of these stories are coming up. Because it's information overload. It's all anybody has been talking about or thinking about or doing for the past week.
一件事，我回家打开电视，打开电脑放在腿上，整天阅读这些东西。在回家的车上，我在听广播电台，自这事发生以来，他们一直在不断地播放，24小时不间断。人们打电话进来，“我们需要这些东西。”诸如此类。我似乎关不掉它。也许我应该关掉。但我认为很多人像我一样。这可能就是这些故事来源的地方。因为这是信息过载。这是过去一周每个人都在谈论或思考或做的事情。
I went to see the lake. It hadn't been drained. The houses around it were gone or badly damaged. The tornado had stripped the trees. They looked like giant sticks stuck in the ground.
我去看那个湖。它没有被抽干。周围的房子消失了或受损严重。龙卷风剥掉了树皮。它们看起来像插在地上的巨大木棍。
David Kestenbaum as part of our Planet Money team. All the songs that we're featuring in today's show, by the way, were released this week. This one is by an Alabama rap group, G-Side featuring Chris Lee, about the tornado.
作为我们“金钱星球”团队成员的大卫·凯斯滕鲍姆。顺便说一句，我们今天节目中播放的所有歌曲都是本周发布的。这一首是阿拉巴马的说唱组合G-Side与克里斯·李合作的，关于龙卷风的。
[MUSIC  - "THE BLACKOUT" BY G-SIDE FEATURING CHRIS LEE]
[音乐 - G-SIDE FEATURING CHRIS LEE的“THE BLACKOUT”]
Thursday night of this week, the first Republican presidential primary debate was held in Greenville, South Carolina. Most of the political world treated it as a joke. The candidates with the best poll numbers skipped it. No Mitt Romney. No Mike Huckabee. Not even Donald Trump. One Republican called the debate "a beauty contest where everybody is ugly."
本周四晚上，第一场共和党总统初选辩论在南卡罗来纳州格林维尔举行。大多数政界人士将其视为笑话。民调数字最好的候选人跳过了它。没有米特·罗姆尼。没有迈克·赫卡比。甚至没有唐纳德·特朗普。一位共和党人称这场辩论是“一场每个人都丑的选美比赛”。
But there's another way to look at this debate. For the few fringe candidates who did show up, this was their one big moment to get noticed. Robert Smith traveled down to Greenville, South Carolina to follow them through the experience.
但看待这场辩论还有另一种方式。对于少数真正出现的边缘候选人来说，这是他们获得注意的唯一大时刻。罗伯特·史密斯前往南卡罗来纳州格林维尔追踪他们的体验。
There's a political rule that applies to even the most minor candidates. Never admit you're losing. No matter how badly you're doing in the polls, you have to pretend that you're one of the big dogs. And that's why it was sort of amazing for me to hear a guy named Herman Cain admit last week that he really, really needed this debate.
有一条适用于即使是最次要候选人的政治规则。永远不要承认你正在输。不管你在民调中表现得有多糟糕，你必须假装你是大佬之一。这就是为什么我听到一个叫赫尔曼·凯恩的家伙上周承认他真的、真的很需要这场辩论时，对我来说感到非常惊讶。
I think that this first debate could potentially move me to what they call, "top tier." There's still a lot of people who don't know who Herman Cain is. So my goal after that first debate is for people to be going, "Who is this guy?"
我认为这场首场辩论有可能让我进入他们所谓的“顶级行列”。还有很多人不知道赫尔曼·凯恩是谁。所以首场辩论后我的目标是让人们去问，“这个家伙是谁？”
Herman Cain is the pizza man. He was the CEO of Godfather's Pizza. And he's never been elected to anything. Cain's poll numbers are mostly non-existent, and by that, I mean not there at all. Most of the pollsters don't even ask about him. But on the morning of the Republican debate he was touring Greenville, South Carolina, breaking another rule of politics-- don't set the expectations too high.
赫尔曼·凯恩是披萨人。他曾是教父披萨的首席执行官。他从未当选过任何职位。凯恩的民调数字基本不存在，我的意思是根本没有。大多数民调机构甚至不问关于他的事。但在共和党辩论的那天早上，他正在南卡罗来纳州格林维尔巡回，打破了另一条政治规则——不要把期望定得太高。
I am here playing to win.
我来到这里是为了赢。
And you're willing to say it.
而你愿意说出来。
And I'm willing to say it. And I want my ideas to cut through all of the political clutter. That's what my goal is tonight.
而我愿意说出来。我希望我的想法能穿透所有的政治杂音。这就是我今晚的目标。
For Cain, this isn't just bluster, because he actually has done this before. He had a moment when he did cut through the political clutter, when he took on the President of the United States. And he won.
对于凯恩来说，这不仅仅是吹牛，因为他实际上以前做过。他曾经有一个时刻确实穿透了政治杂音，当他挑战美国总统时。他赢了。
Thank you very much, Mr. President. Thank you very much for this opportunity. And I would first like to commend you on making healthcare a national priority.
非常感谢，总统先生。非常感谢你给我这个机会。我首先要称赞你将医疗保健作为国家优先事项。
It was 1994 and President Clinton was holding a series of televised town hall meetings about his new plan that would require businesses to provide health insurance. Cain was picked for the audience because he ran Godfather's.
那是1994年，克林顿总统正在举行一系列电视转播的市政厅会议，讨论他的新计划，该计划将要求企业提供健康保险。凯恩因为经营教父披萨被选中进入观众席。
I remember standing up, and that's when they came to me.
我记得站起来，那就是他们找我的时候。
Mr. President, my question is quite simply, if I'm forced to do this, what will I tell those people whose jobs I will have to eliminate?
总统先生，我的问题很简单，如果我被迫这样做，我该告诉那些我必须裁掉的人什么？
Well, let's talk a minute about what you would have to do.
好吧，让我们花点时间谈谈你必须做什么。
If you could design a training program for participating in a presidential debate, this is what it would look like, tussling for eight minutes back and forth with Bill Clinton. What followed was perhaps the most complicated mathematical discussion that's ever been broadcast on prime time. Cain and Clinton were arguing payroll numbers, profit percentages. And the whole time, Cain could feel these TV cameras.
如果你能为参加总统辩论设计一个培训计划，它看起来就是这样，与比尔·克林顿进行八分钟的来回辩论。随之而来的是广播黄金时段播出过的最复杂的数学讨论。凯恩和克林顿在争论工资单数字、利润百分比。在那整个时间里，凯恩能感受到这些电视摄像机。
So I knew that millions of people would be watching me for the very first time in my life. That was probably the most nervous I had ever been.
所以我知道数百万人将有生以来第一次看到我。那可能是我经历过的最紧张的时刻。
OK, first of all, Mr. President, with all due respect, your calculation on what the impact would do, quite honestly, is incorrect.
好了，首先，总统先生，恕我直言，你关于影响的计算，老实说，是不正确的。
A few more minutes of this, President Clinton was ready to move on.
再过几分钟，克林顿总统准备继续下去了。
Let me ask you a favor. Would you send to me personally your calculations?
让我请你帮个忙。你能亲自把你的计算发给我吗？
Even 17 years later, this moment have never faded for Cain. The most animated he gets in our interview is when he talks about the morning after Clinton. His wife came to him while he was in the shower.
即使17年后，这一刻对凯恩来说也从未褪色。在我们采访中他最兴奋的时候是当他谈到克林顿之后的那天早上。他正在洗澡时他妻子跑向他。
Dun, dun, dun. "Herman, you're on CNN and every channel." I said, "What did I do? I didn't kill anybody." I came out, and it was the lead story. Ted Koppel, that night, summarized it, "Last night in Omaha, Nebraska, the pizza man from Omaha stumped President Clinton concerning his health care plan." I was shocked.
当当当。“赫尔曼，你在CNN和每个频道上。”我说，“我做了什么？我没杀人。”我出来时，那是头条新闻。泰德·科佩尔那天晚上总结道，“昨晚在内布拉斯加州奥马哈，奥马哈的披萨人难住了关于他的医疗保健计划的克林顿总统。”我很震惊。
And apparently hooked. Cain started traveling the country giving motivational speeches. He wrote books with titles like, CEO of Self , all about how he became a success in fast food, and brought down the President's health care plan. Herman Cain had tasted glory. And now, in his first presidential debate, he wanted more. Herman Cain on every channel.
而且显然上瘾了。凯恩开始在美国各地进行励志演讲。他写了诸如《自我的首席执行官》之类的书，全部关于他是如何在快餐业取得成功，并击倒了总统的医疗保健计划。赫尔曼·凯恩尝到了荣耀的滋味。现在，在他的第一场总统辩论中，他想要更多。每个频道上的赫尔曼·凯恩。
Every channel, Herman Cain.
每个频道，赫尔曼·凯恩。
Good evening, I'm Bret Baier. Tonight's first Republican presidential debate is being sponsored by Fox News and the Republican Party of South Carolina.
晚上好，我是布雷特·拜尔。今晚的首场共和党总统辩论由福克斯新闻和南卡罗来纳州共和党赞助。
And 17 years later, Cain was back in a live, televised debate. Up on stage with politicians like Congressman Ron Paul, and former Minnesota Governor Tim Pawlenty. The debate started with foreign policy, and Cain struggled to come up with the answers.
17年后，凯恩回到了现场电视辩论中。与罗恩·保罗国会议员和前明尼苏达州州长蒂姆·波兰提等政客同台。辩论以外交政策开始，凯恩努力想出答案。
One of the things that I've always prided myself on is making an informed decision based upon knowing all the facts. And at this point, I don't know all of the facts, but that's the process that I would use.
我一直引以为傲的一件事是基于了解所有事实做出知情决策。而在这一点上，我不了解所有事实，但那是我会使用的过程。
We talked before the debate about his strategy. He told me how he had written out some good lines, was planning to get some jokes in. But up on stage, you could see him making the rookie mistake of actually answering the questions. He wasn't getting that big moment back, even though he tried the same move on the moderator that he tried on Clinton.
我们在辩论前谈过他的策略。他告诉我他写了一些很好的台词，计划加入一些笑话。但在台上，你可以看到他犯了实际回答问题的菜鸟错误。他没能找回那个大时刻，尽管他尝试在主持人身上使用他在克林顿身上尝试过的同一招。
Well, Chris, with all due respect, your experts are dead wrong. Because I have studied the fair tax for a long time. First of all--
好吧，克里斯，恕我直言，你的专家完全错了。因为我已经研究公平税收很长时间了。首先——
But then his answer sort of droned on after that. It turns out that challenging a reporter isn't the same as challenging a president. And it occurred to me as I watched him that I had completely misunderstood that moment in 1994. Herman Cain didn't take down President Clinton and his health care plan. President Clinton elevated Herman Cain. Being on stage with four other also-rans wasn't helping. And this time he was going to have to do it himself. Then, it happened. The moderator, finally near the end, asked a question made for a motivational speaker like Cain.
但之后他的回答在那之后有点嗡嗡作响。事实证明挑战记者和挑战总统是不一样的。当我看着他时我意识到我完全误解了1994年的那一刻。赫尔曼·凯恩没有击败克林顿总统和他的医疗保健计划。克林顿总统提升了赫尔曼·凯恩。与四个其他失败者同台并无帮助。这次他必须靠自己。然后，它发生了。主持人终于在快结束时，问了一个为像凯恩这样的励志演说家设计的问题。
You have an impressive personal history, sir, but why do you have any belief that you stand a chance to win this nomination, let alone the Presidency?
你有一个令人印象深刻的个人经历，先生，但你为什么认为你有机会赢得提名，更不用说总统职位了？
A couple of reasons. Most of the people that are in elective office in Washington, DC, they have held public office before. How's that working for you?
几个原因。大多数在华盛顿特区担任民选职务的人，他们以前担任过公职。效果如何？
Bingo. It turned out to be the catch phrase of the debate. Never mind that he's been trying it out for months. He tried it on us last week.
宾果。事实证明这是辩论的流行语。别管他已经尝试了好几个月了。他上周在我们身上尝试过。
How's that working out for you?
效果如何？
Apparently, quite well. After the debate, Fox News did a focus group. Half the people said Cain won. His staff excitedly told me that after the quip, Cain was the 15th most trending topic on Twitter. But Herman Cain seemed to know that this didn't have quite the same electricity as it did back in 1994.
显然，相当不错。辩论后，福克斯新闻做了一个焦点小组。一半的人说凯恩赢了。他的员工兴奋地告诉我，在俏皮话之后，凯恩是推特上第15个最热门的话题。但赫尔曼·凯恩似乎知道这并没有像1994年那样产生同样的冲击力。
I wouldn't call it a breakthrough, but I would call it a heightened awareness of this guy named Herman Cain. And I hope the takeaway that people had was, we need to take a closer look at this guy.
我不会称之为突破，但我会称之为对这个叫赫尔曼·凯恩的家伙的认识有所提高。我希望人们能得到的结论是，我们需要更仔细地看看这个家伙。
The morning after the debate, I flipped the channels. And Cain was right to be wary of claiming victory. Most news outlets didn't even mention the debate happened.
辩论后的第二天早上，我换了频道。凯恩对声称胜利持谨慎态度是正确的。大多数新闻媒体甚至没提到辩论发生了。
Robert Smith is another member of our Planet Money team. Planet Money is a co-production of our show and NPR News. You can get their free podcasts at NPR.org/money.
罗伯特·史密斯是我们“金钱星球”团队的另一名成员。“金钱星球”是我们节目和NPR新闻的联合制作。你可以在NPR.org/money获取他们的免费播客。
Here's somebody else who had a big week this week.
这里有另一个人本周经历了大事件。
My name is Laura Hucke. I just graduated yesterday at 2 o'clock. And I don't know what I want to do, and I don't know where I want to move. So that poses a problem.
我叫劳拉·哈克。我昨天2点刚毕业。我不知道我想做什么，也不知道我想搬到哪里去。所以这构成了一个问题。
After graduating from the University of Florida in Gainesville on Saturday, Laura got into her car to make a trip that she really hadn't hoped she would be making four years ago. She didn't have a job, so she was moving back in with her parents.
周六从佛罗里达大学盖恩斯维尔分校毕业后，劳拉上了车，开始了一段她四年前真的没希望会做的旅程。她没工作，所以她正搬回父母家住。
1.6 million people will graduate from college over the next month into what is still a very tough economy. This week also happens to be the one year anniversary of when our own intern, Eric Mennel, graduated from college and made the exact same trip to move back in with his parents, jobless. So we sent him along for the ride with Laura.
未来一个月内将有160万人从大学毕业，进入仍然非常艰难的经济环境。本周也恰好是我们自己的实习生埃里克·门内尔大学毕业，并做了完全相同的行程搬回父母家住，失业的一周年纪念。所以我们派他陪劳拉一起走。
When I first showed up at Laura's apartment, she was visibly freaked out. She had just called her mom and dad almost crying.
我第一次出现在劳拉的公寓时，她明显吓坏了。她刚给妈妈和爸爸打完电话，几乎哭了。
I was packing and my trunk was almost full. So I guess I was trying to fit something in there. And I was pushing it in, and I had to put my keys down. And I guess I put them in the trunk because I wasn't thinking very straight. I just closed it, and I'm like, "Yes! It fit." Then I realized my keys are in there. I was just like, of course this would happen when I'm trying to leave, the day I'm trying to leave, you know.
我在打包，我的后备箱快满了。所以我猜我正试着把什么东西塞进去。我把它推进去，我不得不把钥匙放下。我猜我把它放进后备箱里了，因为我头脑不太清醒。我就关上了，我心想，“太棒了！塞进去了。”然后我意识到钥匙在里面。我心想，就在我试图离开时，就在我试图离开的那天，这当然会发生，你知道。
She'd packed mostly the night before. So 30 minutes later when the locksmith showed up, we were on the road.
她前一天晚上大部分都打包好了。所以30分钟后当锁匠出现时，我们就上路了。
When Laura started college, she wanted to be a book editor. She figured she'd live in New York or maybe LA, anywhere but Coral Springs, Florida, where she grew up. But by her senior year, Laura just couldn't get it together to apply for any jobs. She was overwhelmed by all the possibilities. She had no idea where to start. And she battles with a sometimes crippling lack of self-confidence.
劳拉大学开始时，她想成为图书编辑。她想她会住在纽约或也许洛杉矶，除了她长大的佛罗里达州科勒尔斯普林斯之外的任何地方。但到了大四，劳拉就是没能整理好申请任何工作。她被所有的可能性淹没了。她根本不知道从哪里开始。而且她还在与有时严重的自信心缺乏作斗争。
I definitely feel a huge sense of helplessness or something that's really overwhelming. And I'm already in that pit of negativity, of, like, I don't have any experience. I'm never going to get a good job that I want. How am I going to get a job? I have nothing on my resume. All my friends had internships, and they're getting all these amazing jobs, and they're moving away. What's my plan after college? I'm moving back home, like I'm a failure.
我绝对有一种巨大的无助感，或者某种真正令我不知所措的东西。我已经陷入了那种消极的深渊，就像，我没有任何经验。我永远也找不到我想要的好工作。我该怎么找工作？我的简历上一无所有。我的朋友都有实习经历，他们得到了所有这些令人惊叹的工作，他们都要搬走了。大学毕业后我的计划是什么？我要搬回老家，就像我是个失败者。
I don't want to be one those 30-year-old people living in their parents' house. That's just a complete failure. I feel like my whole life people have just told me how smart I am and how I'm so destined for greatness. To not achieve that is just unfathomable.
我不想成为那种住在父母家里的30岁的人。那简直就是彻底的失败。我觉得我整个人生人们一直在告诉我我有多聪明，我注定要成就不凡。没有实现这一点简直不可思议。
When I graduated to move back home a year ago, I spent the first couple of nights sleeping on my kid sister's top bunk. I couldn't land a job. And after two weeks, then a month, then six months without any real sense of direction, it was easily the saddest and most depressed I've ever been in my life. So I felt like I knew what Laura was in for.
一年前我毕业搬回家时，前几个晚上我都在我小妹妹的上铺睡觉。我找不到工作。两周后，一个月后，然后六个月后，没有任何真正的方向感，那是我一生中经历过的最悲伤、最沮丧的时刻。所以我觉得我知道劳拉将要经历什么。
And for one thing, it changes your relationship with your parents. It's awkward. You get annoyed with them. They get annoyed with you. And Laura says she and her mom have always fought a lot, even before this.
而且首先，这改变了你与父母的关系。这很尴尬。你会因为他们而生气。他们会因为你而生气。劳拉说她和她妈妈一直吵得很凶，甚至在这之前。
I'll give you an example of the stupid crap that goes on between me and my mom. I'm sitting at my kitchen table eating lunch, and she's sitting at her desk on the computer, and she's watching a tennis match. And she was saying something about it. And I had said, "Oh. It got postponed because it was raining?" And she goes, "No, it got delayed." And I was like, "Isn't that the same thing?" And she goes, "Well, no. Postponed and delayed are two totally different things." And I'm like, "Well, don't they both mean putting something off to a later time?" I'm like, "Why are you fighting with me about what delayed and postponed is?"
我给你举个例子，发生在我妈和我之间的那些蠢事。我正坐在餐桌吃午饭，她坐在电脑前的桌子旁，她在看网球赛。她在谈论它。我说，“哦。是因为下雨推迟了吗？”她说，“不，是延误了。”我说，“那不是一回事吗？”她说，“嗯，不。推迟和延误是两个完全不同的概念。”我说，“它们不都意味着把某事推到以后的时间吗？”我说，“你为什么要跟我争论延误和推迟是什么？”
Her dad comes out to help her unload stuff for her bedroom. Before she went to college, the room was pink with green carpet. But while she was gone, her parents painted it the color they liked, the color of the rest of the house, brown, which she hates. After talking to Laura's mom, Amy, and dad, Charlie, it's clear that as much as Laura doesn't like the idea of living at home, they wouldn't call it ideal either.
她爸爸出来帮她卸下卧室的东西。在她去上大学之前，房间是粉色的，铺着绿地毯。但当她不在时，父母把它漆成了他们喜欢的颜色，也就是房子其他部分的颜色，棕色，她很讨厌那个颜色。在和劳拉的妈妈艾米以及爸爸查理谈过之后，很明显，就像劳拉不喜欢住在家里的想法一样，他们也不会称之为理想的选择。
My expectation is she's going to come back home and expect it to be like it was before. And I don't think it should be that way. I think she's a grown up now, and she should behave as a grown up. So I see conflict.
我的期望是她会搬回家，并期望一切和以前一样。我不认为应该那样。我认为她现在是个大人了，她应该像大人一样行事。所以我预见了冲突。
From Laura's mom's point of view, that's the main danger here, that Laura won't respect her boundaries and priorities. That she'll act like a kid. I asked about their fights, and what they remembered about the tennis argument.
从劳拉妈妈的观点来看，这儿的主要危险是，劳拉不会尊重她的界限和优先事项。她会像个孩子一样行事。我问过他们的争吵，以及关于网球争论他们记得什么。
She considers it a conflict. I didn't even remember it. You remembered it.
她认为那是个冲突。我甚至不记得了。你记得。
My recollection is that Amy was right and Laura was wrong in the definition of what postponed and delayed were. But when they get into stuff like that, I stay out of it, because I don't want to get in the middle of anything. When you get in the middle of something, you're making a mistake, especially with two of them, because they're both right. So how could I possibly be right, OK?
我的回忆是，艾米是对的，劳拉在对推迟和延误的定义上是错的。但当她们陷入那种事情时，我保持置身事外，因为我不想卷入任何事。当你卷入某事时，你在犯错，尤其是她们两个，因为她们都对。所以我怎么可能对，好吗？
There's something interesting. You said, "As I remember it, Amy was right." So if I was right, why didn't you get involved and stop the argument so it didn't get unpleasant for both Laura and me?
有个有趣的地方。你说，“如我所记得，艾米是对的。”所以如果我对了，为什么你没介入阻止这场争吵，让它不会对劳拉和我都不愉快？
My prognosis-- they're doomed. As of Monday, everyone was still getting along. By Thursday, the story was a little different. Laura's dad went into her room to pull a guitar amp out from under the bed. He had been storing it there while she was away at school. As he was walking out, he bumped into her dresser. The flat iron she uses for her hair fell on the floor. Laura gave him attitude. He got into a fight with his wife over it. As of Friday, Laura still hadn't finished unpacking.
我的诊断——她们完蛋了。周一那天，每个人还在相处。到了周四，故事有点不同了。劳拉的爸爸进她房间从床下拖出一个吉他音箱。她在学校时他一直存放在那。当他走出来时，他撞到了梳妆台。她用来做头发的直发板掉在地上了。劳拉对他态度恶劣。他和妻子为这件事吵了一架。截至周五，劳拉还没完成拆包。
Eric Mennel is our show's intern.
埃里克·门内尔是我们节目的实习生。
[MUSIC - "HELPLESSNESS BLUES" BY FLEET FOXES]
[音乐 - FLEET FOXES的“HELPLESSNESS BLUES”]
Well, our program is produced today by our senior producer, Julie Snyder, and Sarah Koenig, with Alex Blumberg, Ben Calhoun, Jane Feltes, Lisa Pollak, Robyn Semien, Alissa Shipp, and our colleagues at Planet Money, Adam Davidson, Jess Jiang, Chana Joffe-Walt, Caitlin Kenney, and Baldur Hedinsson. Production help from Eric Mennel. Seth Lind is our production manager, Emily Condon's our office manager. Jen Berman's filling in as our West Coast producer. Original newsy but not too newsy sounding music for today's program by Cassettes Won't Listen.
嗯，我们的节目今天由高级制片人朱莉·斯奈德和莎拉·凯尼格制作，还有亚历克斯·布隆伯格、本·卡尔霍恩、简·费尔特斯、丽莎·波拉克、罗宾·塞米恩、阿丽莎·希普，以及我们在“金钱星球”的同事亚当·戴维森、杰斯·蒋、查娜·乔夫-沃尔特、凯特琳·肯尼和巴尔杜尔·赫丁森。感谢埃里克的制作帮助。塞思·林德是我们的制作经理，艾米丽·康登是我们的办公室经理。詹·伯曼正在填补我们西海岸制片人的职位。今天节目的原始新闻风格但不太像新闻的配乐来自Cassettes Won't Listen。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[致谢]
Our website, where you can get our free weekly podcast, thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International. WBEZ management oversight for our show by our boss, Torey Malatia, who's been walking around-- oy-- with this new catchphrase.
我们的网站，在那里你可以获得我们每周的免费播客，thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》由公共广播国际公司发行。我们老板托雷·马拉蒂亚负责我们节目的管理监督，他一直在到处走动——哎呀——带着这个新口头禅。
How's that working out for you?
效果如何？
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
PRI. Public Radio International.
PRI。公共广播国际公司。